to introduce our saturday-morning
keynote speaker mr. Tynan elevated he's
the founder and chairman of US doctors
for Africa also known as USD FA a
nonprofit organization dedicated to
mobilizing volunteer doctors nurses and
other healthcare professionals to
fulfill the overwhelming medical man
Howard leads throughout the African
continent as an internationally
respected humanitarian leader Alamein
who envisions a future for Africa in
which it produces and invest the
economic wealth intellectual capital and
human resources required to provide
medical care to its entire people what
you need to know about the wine that we
affectionately called Ted is that he has
the Midas touch meaning that he is
really able to enlist all sorts of
people across this nation and around the
world to support his efforts he has been
recognized by African heads of state
members of the US Congress US senators
the World Bank the International
Monetary Fund secretary-general Kofi
Anan President Clinton Nasdaq as well as
numerous heads of corporations and
foundations and so I ask you to read his
entire bio sketch in the program but
without further ado and allow him to
truly enlighten us and inspire us and
motivate us to come on board and to join
the movement to bring quality health
care to the continent of Africa
let us warmly welcome
thank you so very much dr. Wallace for
the warm and generous introduction first
and foremost I think before I start my
presentation which will be more of I
think a conversation style that wouldn't
speech or anything that sort before I do
so and I think it's fair and appropriate
to recognize dr. Barbara Wallace and her
team for dedicating her time I'm sure
it's a lot of sleepless nights to
organize these two days conference and I
I am incredibly grateful by this honor
to be invited by dr. Wallace and this
institution that's known around the
world to be most recognized and
respected institutions having say that
before I do my formal presentation I do
have approximately four minutes the
video now that to share with you it's a
rather long PSA but kind of shares the
vision and mission of US doctors for
Africa who's supporting us was a vote
and in that sort so take a look at it
and I'll come back and I'll tell you the
whole story behind this more than that I
wasn't blessed enough to create take it
away
the great Albert Schweitzer once said
therefore search and see if there is not
some place where you may invest your
humanity two-thirds of all known cases
of hiv/aids on planet earth exist in
sub-saharan Africa an estimated twenty
nine point five million human beings
currently infected about the same number
as the combined populations of the
states of New York and Michigan in
Zimbabwe Botswana one in four adults
carries the virus a child born today in
Zambia
or Zimbabwe is more likely than not to
die of AIDS HIV ace has eclipsed malaria
as the number one killer on the African
continent the African hiv/aids pandemic
as well as the alarming re-emergence of
malaria and tuberculosis are insidious
demons as stock and friend the very
future of mankind u.s. doctors for
Africa is an organization devoted to not
only providing direct intervention and
assistance where it is most needed but
also to demystify the dynamic of
communicable disease both on the African
continent and for all the world this is
accomplished through establishing new
lines of communication between
governments partner nongovernmental
organizations or NGOs and medical
institutions augmented by a
state-of-the-art disease tracking and
treatment database that will transcend
physical
and bureaucracy and unify the efforts to
eradicate hiv/aids and other
communicable disease through education
technology and the prevention initiative
is the most obvious work and I hope does
that video give you an idea as to what
this organization is all about and you
will get light the light back right
thank you but we would give you an idea
as far as what the organization is all
about and also have a plan our goals
would be a long term but I think that we
just think couple step back and
recognize the two speakers before me in
particular the gentleman the doctor is
saying here and I don't get it David
went oh yes you know sir I learned a lot
from a 10-6 bit domestic standpoint what
to meet needs or from health care
standpoint and I'm thinking while you're
speaking you're thinking they were think
of Alcantara continents potentially
million times worse and then what we're
facing here the purpose behind
mobilizing binnacle amount power in
creating such a movement or an
organization called us doctors for
Africa is to precisely bring in the
medical teams that are desperately
needed in order to provide direct
medical care for those who don't have
access to currently you heard from Kevin
Walsh and speaking about 12 million
orphans in Africa as well as over 27 or
so million people affected by one
disease and one disease alone that's an
hiv/aids we're not talking about malaria
we're not talking about TV or not
talking about any other communicable
diseases very preventable yet extremely
devastating for the continent because
Africa is
have the title of my market that needs
in order to overcome the challenges that
it's faced the story behind for with the
organization I think is to be more
exciting to you here because I'm not
here to tell you the statistics how many
people are dying every day in Africa
that's a known fact your permanent
enough again and again from the news
papers to the media to Hollywood
celebrities and everybody that speaks on
behalf of Africa I think I've
communicated enough about the desperate
need for a medical marker and the
resources that the continent is
currently facing so I'll be preaching a
choir if I go back and remind you what
that is so I'm not going to waste your
time with that most importantly I think
what we should talk about is what is the
solution we've heard enough of the
problems like 27 million people affected
by one disease 2.5 million people died
last year yeah a very basic in my
opinion I'm not a doctor but a very
basic disease code diarrhea is killing
millions of children throughout the
African continent for anything people
who were not aware of the situation was
sit back and said he gotta be kidding me
right we had a mission that this was not
Marty best doctors but a different
organization send a mission to Africa
and learn about this particular disease
and the fact that millions of kids are
dying from this very very basic
preventable disease and they came back
and said look we gotta do something
about that situation such as the diary
we were talking about HIV in Haiti to
such a complicated disease in such
complicated target that a lot of
resources have been allocated toward
Africa to find aids to create an
awareness and speaking of hiv/aids all
those years that we've been told the
statistics the messengers are very
effective the drug companies are getting
involved right foundations are pouring
billions of dollars in the counter
and there is some progress is being made
but in my opinion is foreign started out
with the concept of us doctors or
Afrikaans
there was one missing cup of this very
complicated puzzle that everybody tried
to solve and the continent does one
chunk of piece of missing that missing
piece is the medical professionals you
know we can pour in all these drugs or
the billions of dollars and everything
else to help that the continent but
unless we have the proper medical
personnel to fulfill or to delivering
these drugs to those who need it most
its job halfway done in my opinion so
that's where over almost eight to nine
years ago what I certain was that soul
searchers my purpose what I wanted to do
in my life I was an accountant working
corporate America in Los Angeles
California
but I knew from day one that it was not
the purpose of my mission in life there
was something better or something that
that needed more value has more allows
you to help the people that I left
behind that I left Africa Ethiopia at
age of thirteen and a half so I mean
same time reading more about the
continent reading enough things about
the people are dying every day 6,000
children will die before the end of this
day that's what statistic said every six
second a child is born HIV positive and
then you hear that there are one doctor
for a hundred thousand people in most
countries in Africa so I mean you just
do the math as far as what the primary
needs or the the crucial approach of
mobilizing copters to go over to Africa
and provide this life-saving care right
so I looked at it from a business town
morning supply and demand issue
one doctor by a thousand people at
America that's Kevin's saying on the
video the continent cover the country
that has tremendous resources and most
importantly people are willing and ready
as long as the message the message
effective communication and the project
and the purpose that inspired them
they're willing to go 20,000 miles from
here
in some cases more to meet people
they've never met in their life before
it's go to a continent they've never
been before to save lives to deliver
disclosure Atlanta cares so I took on
that opportunity and the turning point
of this mobilizing this organization was
after reading the New York Times and
other articles the shortage of medical
professionals in Africa and I think of
myself say wait a minute let me just do
a little bit of digging and see how many
doctors or in America this is just
licensed American medical professionals
practicing Google the number didn't read
a bunch of books and over 850,000
physicians is why statistics told me
said that's brilliant $850,000 Wow
so this is it's great because all I have
to do is form this organization I don't
know what to call him back then right
mobilize fifty or a hundred out of eight
hundred fifty thousand I think that
should be able to organize the team
right so committed my time read about
Doctors Without Borders the Red Cross
and other charities as far as what their
with the background because the last
thing that you want to do is form an
organization that other organization is
exactly what their doors are duplicated
average so really about other
organizations their mission and vision
and work that they do that may be a
clear target clear opportunity to form
this organization because Doctors
Without Borders and similar
organizations or by most notice relief
agencies you know it was the reactor
disasters flood starvation refugee war
and what have you they're doing a
fantastic work all over the world Africa
looking at the continent of Africa
the dire need for a little above we're
not talking about the most sophisticated
medical care that most cases we're not
talking about this the super high-tech
expertise to go in and create a number
of things we're talking about a team
going in and delivering basic medical
care that is what is missing because of
that millions of people are currently
dive so I what I did was after I
followed my passion I found this concept
and another purpose and I have reason to
form this organization come to the US
doctors for Africa the mission was very
simple the mission is to Lola lies the
u.s. doctors and nurses and other health
care professionals who are willing to
give their time short term or long term
to go over to Africa and provide health
care that's what they're trained for
health care based on or specifically on
their expertise and there are HIV
experts fantastic they're nurses
fantastic and as long as they have the
proper training license or the very own
certificate that there are indeed
doctors there welcome to this umbrella
that we create economist dr. Muraki from
the recipient side we have NGOs
government entities foundations are
looking for volunteer doctors to the
nurses and other healthcare
professionals to come and help them
materialize their goals in this case
where there is a primary care or
teaching the local medical health
providers or training or
whatever that may be they can come to
this on grow us calling us doctors for
Africa and we can help them channel this
resources to where they're needed most
so go back to the story I'm going to be
going back and forth so make sure that
they don't get lost
forming this organization then I started
thinking I said wait a minute so this
thing is more organized officially
formed I didn't have board members I
didn't have a set budget to get the word
out and it has they don't care what what
to do next so I had a separate lie to my
house then my bedroom which was the
headquarters of US doctors for Africa
without three machine and there was
maybe two or three pages of website
talks about mission vision my picture
and basic information then I had a Honda
Civic back then and and because I don't
have a budget then I said wait a minute
I got to be a little bit creative so
went to the local signage store where
they make signs and logos and what I
mean I asked them to design the website
address WWI US doctors for Afghan org
that was brilliant
Sunday morning of my lunch break after
work with no reason at all I start
driving around downtown Los Angeles
Beverly Hills California Bel Air where I
felt that these doctors are around so
they can take a look at this logo
Frank and and you know it's of course I
have my little radios on so said I'm
driving around and sometimes I get this
really exciting they blow their horn on
the freewinds a great website I said
thanks so run around then what happened
was the purpose behind this was to get
the word out right and so it just
happened that one day an NPR reporter
driving right behind me on the freeway
so she saw this lolled URL and she got
closer and closer to read it she said
wow she moved back from her office
checked it out I'm not sure if he/she
spent enough time on the website I had
no idea but next thing you know it was a
phone call from her office
somebody had to order some of us doctors
farm but this case it was my bedroom
okay and so after work I come home play
did the little machine and says oh hi
I'm so song with NPR news that we wanted
to story on your foundation I said oh my
goodness this is brilliant
I mean NPR news I listen to anything all
the time and I was going absolutely nuts
some what to do
and the file I returned a phone call and
said look I would tie the spiny show on
NPR nationwide we want you to come with
why don't you volunteer doctors and talk
about the visionary US doctors it's
brilliant
so the first doctor who signed up with
our organization was a good friend of
mine now works with President Clinton's
foundation as a head of their
international law training program we
believe Eric Fleischman to our corner
and I said Eric we're going to be on NPR
news
and he said I love it appearing Ted said
well let's let's get together and expect
what this mission is all about so we
were not it was my first radio interview
I was nervous I was terrified I didn't
even know what to say and I was smiley
and say was to make a long story short
dr. Fleischmann rescue that interview he
talked about what this vision was keep
in mind nationwide people are hearing
this next thing you know 24 hours later
we have hundreds of Falls people say
signing up on the website calling my
voicemail is full every day I can't
dance their mission is full we're
talking about medical students people
who are at training the residency
program retired nurses and doctors that
wanted to join African Diaspora African
physicians that work and live in America
I knew I have something important that
requires my full attention and it
continued dedication for this cause so
we organized a fundraiser we had
missions to South Africa Ethiopia and
Kenya assessment mission to create
partnerships with the local NGOs
creating in the relationship but
introductory with the Minister of Health
of of this countries and I wrote a
letter to members of Congress and
basically enough for African ambassadors
back then to introduce the US doctors
for Africa organization not asking for
funding or anything else just say no us
that we exist and when we're prepared
that we need your help we'll be reaching
out to you but but just keep that in the
back of your mind boy the the response
the endorsement the excitement the
energy behind this cause was beyond my
imagination was incredible so fast
forward we can create a partnership when
we started deploying physicians to
clinics and hospitals with a minimum
funds that we raised with fundraising
events and direct contributions our
friends who
companies and what-have-you so the first
four years of this organization which
we've been around almost like I said
eight plus years now was to build the
foundation building well though the
medical mom power for willing in
productivity volunteered their time and
expertise then I'll have an excuse to go
to Congress to Bill Gates to anybody
else and say I have this money
physicians willing and ready to go and
to have the continent of Africa and we
know the funding is there we know for a
fact their Africa needs physicians and
other health care providers to fulfill
the gap to train the local doctors and
nurses and to mentor the midwives and a
number of admission that that's think
that's being discussed too but WH o or
UNICEF or the president's emergency fund
and what have you so we knew that we had
something as special and very crucial so
we did that and everybody is now aware
of this organization I've hundreds of
people signed up I don't know what to do
it because there's a lot of people who
signed out I need a lot of money to get
them where they need to go but the
number continued to build we kept in
touch with most of our volunteers
letting them know that we're the process
of raising funds and what time comes
they'll be approached for deployment
then we did a number of missions to
Ethiopia and South Africa and a few
other countries which is on the website
you can take a look at it and then
because the number of volunteers grew we
decided to create a membership
opportunity there's no due but doctors
and nurses can sign up as members of US
doctors for Africa again the purpose is
to have that core team dedicate a team
that can be called upon whether time
comes and the project exists so what
happens after the guid the word went out
and a lot of people heard about us one
day
which is a I still remember that I'm
sitting in my office but this time we
have actual office by the way and yes we
do we do have a nice office which was by
the way as donated by a gentleman who
actually have a nice big office in Los
Angeles donated by a gentleman who heard
by the US doctors far I've got invited
me to lunch and he said that I heard
this whole thing that you trying to do
and I know that your office is your
bedroom so if you ever need office space
them you know I say absolutely
immediately we need one it's almost
literally 24 hours later he gave me the
key to an office in a very expensive
area in Los Angeles all this years now
that we have that own headquarters which
the organization is not paying for which
is very exciting and so that's what
people got inspired to understand the
vision of this organization in what it
can fulfill a short term or long term
now going back to the phone call that I
received from President Clinton's office
which is the turning point most exciting
part of this never thought in my wildest
dream that someone from President
Clinton's office will call me to talk
about a possible partnership with US
doctors for Africa
I knew though I knew we had a great
organization but we're not prepared to
face you know this this big big
partnerships and what have you so phone
call came in and and there was a chief
of staff for a child which is clearly
Chinese initiative and said look you
know we want to talk about it as far as
strategic partnership between US doctors
for Africa and the Clinton Global
Initiative hiv/aids program and I was
thrilled said that this is fantastic
absolutely right because we know what
we're gonna provide which is our bagel
manpower but of course President Clinton
has worked tirelessly you continue to do
so to find aids and other communicable
diseases throughout the country
throughout the continent lots of
resources soon are being deployed
there was a privilege and honor to
actually be asked to partner with with
your initiative so we did so in our
first deployment was in Tanzania and
then the word went out to different
foundations so the phone calls came and
I get to be invited to a number of
meetings and and and what have you which
is also very exciting so with more
notoriety and with more resources there
are more responsibilities and so that
responsibilities become as a leader of
this organization one sort of new and
attractive and doable initiative can we
introduce to the public and so therefore
the public will believe that we do in
fact have a powerful message and a
powerful project that they can back us
up last year and again most of the
information should be on the website and
there's a lot more it's not so you more
than welcome to take a look
last year I was invited to participate
with the Clinton Global Initiative which
is another powerful leadings that
President Clinton is able to organize
leaders from around the world come to
discuss very pressing issues that's
facing the global others the environment
or healthcare or what have you in that
day we were asked to make a commitment
the organization as far as what would be
the next approach from US doctors for
Africa what do we envision whether or
not what we're proposing is in fact
something capable of fulfilling so we
talked about a number of things with my
team what that commitment would be and
we realized that currently we have
several thousand volunteer medical
professionals signed up with US doctors
for Africa which is the great
accomplishments thus far we've had a
number of missions based on the funding
resources that we've
now I think you'd be perfect if we do
something that would go along with the
medical a power that we have so I said
to my team look it it's great to have
all this but the next commitment should
be to deploy mobile clinics throughout
Africa it made a lot of sense because
now we have enough medical lab are
joined by the mobile clinic and we know
that some approximately 85% of Africa
population live outside of big cities
and towns in other words they live in
rural Africa though so the people are
most affected by these diseases most of
the people are dying from preventable
disease or those who live in rural
Africa and so this concept or this
commitment of launching mobile clinics
made a lot of sense so that the idea is
to bring healthcare to wear this people
live because they don't have access to
come to the big cities it tells us to
receive the proper language care that
commitment was something that a lot of
folks that praised and endorsed and of
course this is 15 to 20 years commitment
of deploying 200 mobile clinics to
sub-saharan Africa and I'm happy to say
that were ahead of schedule in fact our
first mobile clinic is on its way to
Africa now
last week
so the whole goal is keep in mind and
I'm sure we understand that big picture
of having this mobile clinics driving
around the small towns and giving
vaccinations given the proper care to
woman who's ready to give birth but she
doesn't have access to transportation
and therefore this clinic will be there
to provide that very life-saving
treatment and care I know however I
think two more minutes left am i right
okay so five super so having said that
now we have engaged in deployed mobile
clinics with our medical mom park tool
and I do need to remind you that and
again having no expertise in any
healthcare professional my vision was
I've heard enough
very powerful message from various areas
very powerful statistics from experts
like the previous speakers here head of
states movie stars head of religion
groups Christian Muslim Jew and what
have you this is the problem is powerful
enough to bring all these people
together and the fact that Africa has
always been the worst victim of this
preventable diseases that's wiping out
of the society and I think playing a
small but effective role such as
mobilizing a team they can go over save
lives come back home I don't care how
long they stay there two months six
month and you I think it's and they came
back saving two lives or a hundred lives
and my opinion admission
accomplished okay so that has been the
purpose I'm grateful to say that now we
have a lot of volunteers the
organization continues to grow more
funding sources coming our way
lots of Hollywood celebrities if you
flip through this are indeed in fact the
PowerPoint to go toward the end you will
see the endorsement that we've had from
a number of Hollywood folks and the
mission goes on now domestically for 30
seconds domestically what have we
achieved
we all remember four years ago hurricane
Francis that destroyed literally
destroyed Florida in the Box two years
ago we had Hurricane Katrina and in Rita
I don't need to preach the part again
you know what happened so we tapped into
our resources and deployed our volunteer
physicians to New Orleans that the
governor was kind enough to recognize
for our service to the Bahamas four
years ago hurricane Francis we were one
of the few US organizations to mobilize
nationwide to organize baby food diapers
and food and shelter attendants and what
have you I had a gentleman from New York
City very well often when with the
private jet offered his jet to take our
doctors from whatever they are to the
Bahamas and do the service and fly it
back again and that happened and of
course we anonymous for me coming to get
it effectively but talking about the
organization's commitment and the
passion that we have to warm saving
lives and again to wrap this up it's
there's a lot of information you can
find on the website I will be more
to answer any questions you may have but
it's a privilege to me to be able to
fulfill my vision and a great blessing
to have thousands of people across this
nation around the world follow this
vision that help us grow and to fulfill
our ultimate goal which is to Train poor
medical professionals to save lives to
mobilize and create a unique
relationship between these two nations
the United States of America and the
continent of Africa that in fact they
need each other for our perspectives so
I mean say that thank you for you for
your time and I am truly honored to come
and present intend to reduce the
organization if you have any questions
I'll be more than happy to take and if
not I'll be here all day
so be available
every discovery and listening to one of
his favorite words is brilliant but if
there's anything or anyone who's really
it's Ted and his vision it's an
absolutely brilliant vision you know in
addition you can see that it's about 1/4
to ative event or connection after
another and so we're hoping that what
happens today at our gala fundraising
dinner is that we come together and are
able to contribute something to honor
Ted now of course now I'm very
embarrassed because my favorite black
company in California did not deliver
the plaque yesterday and they're closed
on Saturday it's a family business but
because we have this nice photographer
here I had one of my students go get a
muse as you know use what you have not
what you want kind of the African Way
use what you have so we're going to
angle this plaque so that you can't meet
the words but you see that I'm giving ok
so let me read the third annual health
disparities conference is giving to Ted
the Harriet Tubman okay I mean as the
director of the third annual health
disparities conference I am delighted to
present the Harriet Tubman Freedom Award
for outstanding global community
activism and lifetime achievement to
improve health honoring Ted and alum a
moon founder and chairman of the
doctors for Africa for being the kind of
visionary leader who inspires and
mobilizes others to action within a
global movement and mission to bring
quality health care to Africans in
Africa March 8 2008 third annual health
disparities conference Teachers College
Columbia diversity
this is a photograph of the US doctors
for Africa mobile clinic number one
February 2000 baby rate 27 2008 a
photograph he's gonna love this now we
should probably have dr. Judy Kerensky
to come up here now but you're gonna
you're gonna stay just for a moment Ted
because when I didn't have a correct
plaque and now please clone you could
you put this back in the box
so some of you know dr. judy korean ski
she's a acclaimed sex therapist clinical
psychologist professor in our department
of clinical accounting psychology here
and someone who is just so present and
so full of love that it just blows us
away so i also asked her i was lamenting
oh we don't have a plaque so dr. judy
said we'll just give him some of these
so therefore not a crime to my
autographed her to book sticker a speaks
and what about her mentor and the
tradition from which she comes and then
the CD because the performance yesterday
was great so she's autographed all three
of these so because of dr. judy you get
more than just a plaque for your wall
which is for equity and health a new
global approach to health disparities
and then the hiv/aids for education
training manual autographed with and
just you know burgeoning with our love
and respect for you thank you so much
and I know my time has expired so enlist
apologize look I am stunned by this
surprise but it is incredible because
this is what the movement is all about
is to deploy this mobile clinics that
you're looking at and better came to
Washington and I had a brief press
conference for the local TV and in those
who supporters to actually show these
this mobile clinic before it so it's
going to Maryland Airport and Baltimore
um so this means a lot dr. Barbara
Wallace I don't once again thank you
simply and it's not so much that I can
say but I always sandwich in English was
my first language is gonna think also
but a truly tuning grateful okay and I
do thank you very much of course my
colleague dr. Judy is is simply
incredible
for him taking our time to join us
doctors to spread the word in the New
York area and I think as we grow sure
instrumental player in this movement so
thank you again
as Ted said this is fantastic
great honest to you Barbara and for us
all making the commitment yesterday that
you made us gift that we can repeat
again that Barbara said I'm calling for
a 21st century global civil rights
movement for equity and health for all
I'm very inspiring I couldn't get it out
of my mind all day yesterday and all
night last night and all day today and
that is indeed what we are calling for
in all Barbara's words yesterday morning
fits so perfectly into the mission for
us stocks the every concept the civil
rights aspect of it the opportunity for
equity in health the serving those who
need it and the Global Initiative so I
get goosebumps thinking about that in
fact if we all in our bedroom had things
happening like what Ted created it would
be an astounding new world yes right you
heard Ted describe the medical services
that US stock has been providing and the
exciting deployment of the mobile clinic
just last week to Ethiopia from
Washington DC another initiative that US
Stas has undertaken at Ted's brilliance
is the psychosocial arm of this project
that has been focusing on medical
services Barbara's conference here
stress and Barbara talked about
yesterday the services for physical
for mental health and for spiritual
health and so the new initiative for the
US stocks is to include those other
multidisciplinary and multi-dimensional
aspects into the project so we invite
you to join the psychosocial arm of US
stocks for Africa and dr. Wallace has
been so gracious and so generous to
offer us the opportunity to have the
regional meetings here in New York and
here at this conference to include those
other dimensions the psychosocial arm
and to facilitate and build the team
here starting here and then growing for
US stocks on these multi-dimensional
levels so please join us for those
meetings it's in your program starting
at 2:15 and mill back Bank chapel which
is actually in the main building of
gorgeous Chapel it is the most
inspirational place truly to start this
initiative so I look forward to seeing
you there at 2:15 at little Bank Chapel
for the team building for US stocks this
is an outgrowth of the initiative that
we had just recently in February where
an assessment team went down to New
Orleans
Ted talked a lot about the amazing work
that u.s. dothis is doing to serve the
continent of Africa so dyli needed we
all know how needed similar services are
right here and right down south in New
Orleans and
those affected by Katrina what we found
was that everyone we spoke to them from
the aging home to the teen services to
the volunteer NGO said that they are
suffering emotionally now years later
still from the aftermath of that
devastation and they are desperately in
need of health and support from those of
us who can do something to help our
neighbours down south and so we have
initiated a project in the Lower Ninth
Ward and other needed areas that is
extremely exciting to offer the mobile
clinics and psychosocial services so
please join us at 2:15 in Milbank chapel
and thank you all for being here for
your hearts and your minds I appreciate
it
you
the preceding program was brought to you
by Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes tc
Columbia edu